welcome to my first video 2015 this
looks promising
welcome to fight IRA if you didn't know
fried ire II is a diary of my week in
video form so much stuff has happened
this week and I didn't necessarily film
as much of it as I should have but let's
go back in time and relive this week I
flew back to Los Angeles
so I am back in LA and I'm opening a
bunch of packages thing I guess we're
dropped off here as gifts and fullscreen
got me the selfie stick oh I don't know
if I explained to you guys but I am I'm
back in Los Angeles for a couple days
because my parents are here visiting
they're coming to see my house why are
you being so distant it doesn't make me
any less shaky though they're gonna go
see my house and then I'm gonna go back
to New York for New Year's school okay I
like my lighting like I like my breakups
harsh nope
it is currently 105 I said yeah 105 a.m.
Tuesday Tuesday it is Tuesday I've been
like so not on the internet at all today
because my mom and my said I came into
town and they helped me do domestic
things because their parents and they
want to feel a part of me and my house
situation so we went to Ikea
you see in the distance out there
there's a newly purchased vacuum very
exciting business but right now she just
got back from Han this house I got to
see Hannah and say hi and I'm sorry I
didn't film it because and it is a
French then sometimes I don't film when
I'm with friends but here's how it could
have gone yeah Wow
I went wine tasting with my family and
memories family at the vineyard new went
wonhae USA that has a safari tour and
wine tasting in one it's just awesome
mom Hema a sock satyrs eggs and what are
you most excited for I wanna see dress
okay classic wine tasting
my parents are staying in my house while
I'm in New York and this is them trying
to put the duvet cover back on the duvet
you guys are doing a great job you all
go they get back to New York City for
New Year's
and then I spent these past two days
after engineers literally doing nothing
happy 2015
this January first it's 7:20 p.m. and I
had a great New Year's with great people
I spent all day in bed today except I
got up once to get the delivery ramen
soup that I ordered and dumplings and
also got up a second time to put this
face mask on and to brush my teeth in my
hair just to feel kind of human I think
it's good to start the year off on a you
know
below average note and then build
yourself up to all those resolutions
don't go too hard too fast when you had
to run the mile for the president's
physical fitness session there's always
that kid that's printed the first lap
and you were like God Terry and then
they send it walking because I couldn't
maintain it's hard to maintain if you go
too hard too fast
I think I'm doing a good job maintaining
hope you guys had a great New Year's see
in the next clip it's 4 p.m. on Friday
and I just woke up and I don't know how
or why but I slept in till 4:00 so now
to make something of the day I'm gonna
go try and do New Year's type resolution
and stuff
I did exercise now I'm doing salad yay
New Year feeling great and now we're
here and I'm so excited to start 2015
there are so many cool things that are
going to be happening in 2015 and one
that I'm really excited about I don't
have all of the information about it
just yet but as soon as I do you will
know I am going to London the 20th
through 25th of this month January to do
some book signings there for Grace's
guide the art of pretending to be a
grown-up and I'm really pumped I love
London
you guys are so damn polite if you don't
like me you at least keep it to
yourselves and you repress it deep down
you don't outwardly say it which is cool
thanks some of the book signings have
gotten tweeted out but not all of them
and so as soon as I know you will know
follow me on other social media
platforms Twitter Tumblr Facebook
Instagram vine snapchat etc to know all
of that information one really huge
thing it's getting announced any day now
so just look out for that
other than that I hope you had a great
New Year's I don't know
all the sirens in New York City sounds
of sassy they're just like Oh get out of
the way you don't actually like
sarcastic we get it